to what degree is there corruption in
senegal in africa
and
um how do we fix it
so when you said to which degree there
is corruption i will respond to you the
same i respond to people i say yeah we
have corruption and it's almost as bad
as in chicago yeah right so um
now what i want people to understand
when it comes to corruption
it's uh because we are misguided with
corruption
we think corruption is the root cause of
problems when corruption is simply
a symptom of a deeper
root problem
in this case
um if you make the laws
so
senseless
meaning let me give you an example of
senseless laws
every time i have to import something in
my country
i have a business
we're making lip balms in this case and
others uh skincare products
some ingredients i'm able to find in the
country at the standard that i need in
order to remain competitive
because for example our products are
sold whole foods market you can
understand it's a pretty sophisticated
and really you know
they don't just put anybody on the
shelves
but the thing is
it means that on the other end
my inputs has to be right
so out of those some
we have seven ingredients seven items
that need to come from abroad
to go into the making of this product
some packaging and some raw material
but guess what
likes for five of them
i am paying a 40 tariff
and 402 almost 70 tariff
that i call senseless laws
these tariffs
are senseless
yeah corruption is just a symptom they
reveal that something is broken about
the law exactly
and the laws are so taxation
um
this kind of
restricting laws like laws that slow
down the entrepreneurial momentum they
do they do because in this case when my
product comes
what do people have to do
because every time you if you add 40
you're basically on the other end so
every time you add um if let's say my
product normally
cost a dollar and with your 40 by the
time i'm done i had to pay i had now
it's costing me 140. by the time it
arrives in my warehouse
in my manufacturing facility it's now at
140 because of a tariff i left behind
that 40 you added to it do you know how
much it's gonna add to my final cost but
once the product is finished i have to
sell it to the customer
i have to sell it for 1.60 more because
of that 40 cents uh extra you took from
me
in order for me at the end of the day
to have some type of profits because
profits at the end of the day
is uh the blood of a business there are
two people are misguided they say oh you
dirty greedy business people and it's
all about profit profit profit profit
you know
i belong to this organization called i'm
a board member under conscious
capitalism
it is the largest organization of
purpose driven
businesses and entrepreneurs
the type of people i told you about we
start our businesses because we we see
something that needs to be to be taken
care of in society whole food market is
one of them the container store
you know all of these companies that are
beloved in the u.s but you can hear of
we believe
that the end goal of business is purpose
but in order to do purpose
you have to have profits
to stay in to stay alive
and the best way for people to think of
profits so that they not all twisted
about it
lex if i asked you
what's your goal in the world
you're probably going to tell me your
dream you're going to talk to me about
what you're doing right now and how you
want to be uniting you want a more
harmonious world you want human
flourishing that's what you're working
towards that's what you say to me you're
not going to say well my biggest goal in
the world is to produce as many red
blood cells as i can
except you need to produce verse
otherwise no legs and if no legs
no one working
yeah you know what i mean yeah so that's
how so people need to stop with this
whole prophet not
do we have some
psychopaths among us yeah one person of
us in this world are psychopaths in
every field anywhere you look and surely
you find that in the entrepreneurial
entrepreneurs world as well yeah so we
have one person of us who are psychopath
for sure but do they define the rest of
us absolutely not and thankfully not
so
let's just be clear on that so here the
you know
my
you charge me 40 tariff which is
outrageous
then you're forcing me to sell it 4.60
more than my competitor who does not
have to go for that nonsense because
she's an american woman who is operating
in america and she doesn't have that
nonsense put on her so now i'm on this
market competing against this woman eye
to eye
so if we're selling the same value
product
mine cost a dollar sixty more simply
because of some stupid rules from back
home
then guess who is going to stay in
business and who does it
see they want to talk about equality
that's the type of equality i want to
see the playing love the level the
playing field has to be leveled told you
english is a life of language so there's
two two people talking
between us maybe we have this english
thing figured out
we'll have it figure it out so
the the the idea of capital is the idea
of conscious capitalism is the the thing
that in large part enables this level
playing field
that's what we want so so what you're
trying to say so here so when i talked
about census laws that's an example so
when you make when you make the tariffs
so high
that and you're going to render me um
you know
non-competitive
then
that's where for people who might make
sense
when the product arrives at port
they say hey
i give you this
what i give you maybe it's ten percent
of the price or five percent it's surely
not forty percent but you
are happy with it you've a government
official that's what we call a bribe and
me i'm like hey i saved myself money and
um also i saved myself time
but you see if the laws where you pay
five percent or even the ten percent but
i just left behind or nothing you come
you paid you move on because who has the
business of fooling around and staying
behind and no you do that when it's
actually uh makes sense to do that so
i'm not sitting here telling people i
engage in unlawful practices in my case
because i'm around saying the things i'm
saying right now so i'm a target
you have to do things cleanly and i
believe in doing things that way so what
i had to do was go to the
ask again mayor
we have a problem
whenever he sees me he's like now what
i'm like we've got a problem you're best
friends now
so i say now it's the customs
and uh and it's like what do you want me
to do i said do you know anybody at
customs i need to hire up at customs
because i got to explain to them what's
going on here they all know of course
but i think they're not always maybe
understanding or maybe they understand
and in this case he understood
so we went
and he's like yeah i know this is not
this is not very yeah this
and i said what do we do now and i saw
him going through binders and binders on
in his office because he's gonna try to
go and look where
in the law
can we find something that can help me
escape
these rules
and you know the best he found lex was
oh well here see
this one if you've been in business for
two years
then uh we can allow you there is a
special term for this which french is
technical we can allow you to bring your
raw material
but you have to tell us exactly
how much you're bringing and it has to
match your formulation because you know
they don't want you to bring in more
that we need and maybe sell some of that
to the rest of the market and they
didn't make their money on it
so
there it means i have to give them my
recipe imagine coca-cola being asked to
give their secret sauce
to government officials
in a country that you can't even know
what might happen let alone even in
business you don't do that i mean
straight secrets are trade secrets but
here you're asked to be putting it in
front of some people you don't know
where it's going to go after that
because there they get to see okay her
recipe calls for
x amount of um
of candida wax x amount of um
coconut coconut oil okay and on top of
that we have to think about how much
porridge might they be or not because
again we don't want her to to to buffer
it over there so you have to get naked
in front of them in terms of your recipe
which might end up only god knows where
tomorrow maybe competitive competition
or maybe even them they started business
and they compete with you because we've
seen that so um you have to do that and
then each time file fill out the
paperwork get the approval then it can
come in so when you can come in you
don't have to pay that tax oh and by the
way you only have you have one year one
year to make this product and get it out
and all of it needs to be back out
because if it's any of it stays here
you're gonna pay the the taxes that we
held up so you're basically forced
by these
uh suspicious laws yes to be dishonest
all of this was so it's so cumbersome
because each it means more paperwork
paperwork everywhere maybe having to
disclose your thing so me in my case
what i did is um
you know this person said okay we're
gonna see how we can how we can work
with you but uh for the first two years
we were more or less in the gray area
yeah so
so even gray area is good
yeah but but let's what does it mean in
a situation like that whenever they want
to mess with you
it means they can come and they will
look and they will find something so it
means that every day i'm trying to do
business i'm running the risk of being
harassed and or maybe even put in jail
depending on what it is yeah
i mean
you're an incredible person because it
seems like
there's two ways to change this
become
president or gain power in the country
and to try to change the laws
which seems really difficult to do and
the other way is
fight through the laws and create the
business anyway build the business
community and through that method create
a huge amount of pressure
change the laws you're totally getting
it by with your last part because this
is the other thing and this is where
i get so upset sometimes with um my
fellow africans because they get so
disgusted by what they're seeing right
and they think the answer is to go for
politics let's go be president let's go
be this let's go be that and we're going
to change everything i see that in the
u.s too people thinking that presidents
have all this power do you know who has
released power in government for
president i mean people don't get that
um your best bet uh if you're gonna if
you insist on going into politics stick
to the local level that's where all the
skeletons are buried and hidden and
that's where you can make the most
impact local level i know it's not shiny
i know it's not exciting but that's
where it's at so if you must go into
politics but there's another way so in
my case what i do is two things
i preach and i practice i preach when
i'm here talking to you about this i'm
preaching i am sharing with people that
is which i found and by the way the
answer was there
i was doing these two businesses
realizing the difference in treatment of
um the doing business environment of the
us compared to the doing business
environment of senegal
and at first i was like of course us
everything is messed up it's because
we're poor country
but when i started to put two and two
together i'm like
you're poor because you have no money at
least not enough money to take care of
your basic needs you have no money
because you have no source of income
where does a source of income come from
for most of us it comes from a job
doesn't it
and in some people sometimes at my uc
berkeley class they say oh no it comes
from government too
i'm like i would like to think that even
if you work for government you're going
to be paid something right and they're
like yeah and then even before i can say
something we're like oh
yeah because that money we used to pay
our public officials
comes from taxes you know employers
employees we go back to the private
sector for most of it from where this
whole thing is created so
it's clear
your poor because have no money no money
because no source of income source of
income for most of us is a job we're
talking about so where do jobs come from
the private sector primarily small and
medium-sized enterprises then don't you
think
that we should make it easy
that we should have
a friendly
doing business environment
and also a lot of the a lot of it comes
not just from the
small medium sized businesses
but i think a lot of the values created
from new ones being launched yes right
it's not just like me like saving
somehow through regulation the ones that
are already there no
no it's like it's letting the market
letting the new better ideas yes
flourish yes it's about what i mean by
doing business environment is all the
things that you and i talked about
earlier
even the access of electricity is part
of a doing business for doing business
so basically when i've discovered all of
that when i put all these dots together
then i'm like well i guess um business
and it makes sense lex if you want to
grow tomatoes you're gonna have to have
two things one is a good seed
right that has good attributes
and then you're gonna have to have
um a good environment for it
is the soil the right one
what's your ph level
all of those good nutrients we're gonna
put in it is it in a place that has tons
of sun how much sun exposure or not the
climate engine or is it going to be cold
not not you can't have some beautiful
tomatoes in the middle of siberia last
time i checked so same thing here you
know mohammad yunus the noble um
laureate uh in for peace said
poor people are bonsai people
they're the same people
if you put them in the normal natural a
friendly habitat
where they can thrive they become the
tallest tree in the forest
poor people are bonsai people so you see
that tiny pot you put around the bonsai
tree
that's the tiny pot that created by
giving me such a hostile business
environment
that
basically were put together by the set
of laws that you have put that basically
i have to jump through as a business
person practicing business in my country
if you turn that environment into a
friendly environment where i am not
married to my employees i have
flexibility of uh the labor laws are
simple straightforward clean where the
tax code is very simple it's not worth
truckloads of laws like in my country
it's so complicated you have to hire a
cpa which costs more money and even them
tell them girl we're going to make some
mistakes they don't they don't talk to
me like that it's not you know they
don't send me gold they shouldn't
they better not but they say
whatever they say
i'm scared
you know
you know they're like we're gonna but
bottom line is we're gonna make mistakes
this thing is so complicated we're gonna
make mistakes so which means my ass is
on the line so anyway so
so if the tax code was so simple
straightforward like it is maybe in
texas where up till a threshold you owe
me nothing go online five minutes fill
out your taxes you're you're compliant
keep bring keep building your business
because that's what we need from you if
you made it so easy
and straightforward
then you know what that's when you get
all of these people likes what you're
talking about saying you know what
my name
is aminetta and i live in the middle of
nowhere senegal but you know what i've
got this great idea which is for this
really hot nice hot sauce but i know the
americans are gonna love i'm hearing but
hot sauce is a big thing
let me bring it to them but everything
is there for you to jump into the ring
of entrepreneurship you don't have to
know someone like my god you don't have
to even have the ability to sell
yourself maybe like i can sometimes
you are
someone with a great idea you're willing
to work hard for it and pour everything
you got into it guess what
it's fair you can get into the race you
can be a dreamer
and you can be a dreamer in a rural
little village and then that has ripple
effects throughout the entire country
young kids growing up you know i want to
be the next ex yes whatever and it
doesn't have to be you know the next
steve jobs that that seems really far
far away all levels it's at all levels
you you create uh local heroes
because because um because
representation matters yes right
so and we are so badly in need of that
and so um so that's what all the things
that have been stolen from us as long as
things remain the same so lex once i
found out that basically at the end of
the day
the answer is economic freedom and that
when it comes to that the indexes
economic indexes that measure that
whether it's the dream business index
ranking of a world bank or the fraser
economic freedom index
of the heritage foundation when you look
at all of those indexes and others what
do they have in common
one after another they show you
that it is
harder to do business in almost anywhere
in sub-saharan africa than it is
per se
anywhere in scandinavia so it is telling
you that scandinavian nations that
socialist americans tend to love so much
and take as an example over there too
they're showing you that they don't
understand what's going on really in
scandinavia
that scandinavia is more capitalist
scandinavian nations are more capitalist
than almost any sub-saharan african
nations
ultimately
the political systems actually don't
even matter nearly as much
as the private sector of being able to
operate the machinery of capitals there
you go there you go there you go and
it's almost like um like i said it's
almost like its own little widget within
within it you can have whatever type of
society you want to practice you want to
exercise at whatever level you want to
but if you're serious about becoming a
low amid a middle to high income nation
there is no other pathway that we know
of at this point
and you know what made me
super excited about that beyond having
finally
found my answer
i have to tell you when i found that
answer i literally fell to my knees
it was a type of feeling that
you know
if something is not well with you
whether it's physical or mental
something is not well you're not well
and you go around and you go to the
so-called specialist some of them you
know but you're going around for years
going around trying to get help
for your ailment
and
here they don't know here they tell you
things that
you can't tell why but you just know
it's not true
they're this they're bad and it's it's
going on for years after year after year
and finally you meet this one person
and boom
it's there
not only the liberation
but also this whole new world that comes
with it
you know i'm still
i'm still ill
but guess what
there's a path forward
we know that
i am i'm gonna have a lot of work to do
but there's hope yeah right and you're
the uh the beacon of hope actually for a
lot of people in that part of the world
and that's those beacons are actually
really necessary so not only is there
hope but you can
uh become
i mean
the beacon for your people your your
your home this this power that you see
that you feel all around to become
uh
to escape the feeling of being
trapped
you